all right welcome back everybody so this
is the 13th lecture of the class uh this
is as close to Friday the 13th we're
going to get this month um midterm is
going to come out on Monday uh I'll
probably release it after class it'll be
due on Wednesday probably at 5:00 and
there will be no office hours on Tuesday
or Wednesday
okay okay so in the last lecture we
talked about Odes with forcing and so
now we're going to go into some really
really powerful stuff related to
convolution integrals for General
systems so we're going to start looking
at General
systems like X do equal Matrix a * X
plus some input forcing Matrix B times a
input Vector U okay so before we've been
looking at this first part for kind of
unforced linear dynamical systems and
now we're going to add this forcing term
but before I do that I want to uh just
kind of motivate this type of equation
with an example from the
homework so writing a system as a linear
OD plus a linear forcing term can be
extremely general for linear feed back
control
okay so the example that we have from
class is this Theta double dot equals
minus sin theta plus some uh torque
to just to draw the picture of this
we're going to be thinking about the
inverted
pendulum with angle Theta and we're
going to be applying some control torque
tow okay
this is essentially forcing at the base
of this
pendulum and so we're going to
essentially cook up a tow that
stabilizes this inverted pendulum system
that's what we're doing on the homework
uh so this is about the theta equals Pi
solution so I can write down Theta dotal
Omega Omega do equal minus
sin theta plus
to and if I linearize about the unstable
fixed point this theta equals Pi we get
something like
DDT uh of
theta Omega
equals
01 1
0 but now we have this additional plus
01 *
to okay so we can can write down our OD
in this
form and this is exactly like uh the
system we've written
up uh on the left board so this term is
like my Vector x
dot this is my Matrix a and my Vector
X and this is my uh Matrix B in this
case it just happens to be a column
vector and this is my forcing U
Okay so we've taken this differential
equation for the inverted pendulum with
forcing and I've written it in this uh
simple form in terms of matrices and
vectors okay X do equals Matrix a * X
plus some other Matrix times my input
forcing
okay and this is really the basis for
all of feedback control theory okay so
feedback control allows you to change
the linear dynamics of a system by
adding some uh external forcing of
you're choosing so usually you get to
measure some quantities and you get to
feed them back and try to stabilize your
system so here our feedback is going to
be
um our feedback is going to be
to equal - 2 Theta - 2 Omega
and remember this Theta has already been
linearized about Pi so this is really my
difference
from the upright Pi
position okay and if I plug this
in I find that this whole thing is like
0 1 1
0 time Theta
Omega
plus okay I get zero contribution from
from this torque in the first row
equation but I get - 2 Theta - 2 Omega
in the second row equation because
that's what my my torque tow is equal
to so this is like a min-2
min-2 Time Theta
Omega this is the effect of my forcing
towel I just cooked up this tow it's
then it took me a little while to figure
out that this is a really good tow that
actually stabilizes the system but when
we plug this in we can write this whole
equation
DDT of theta
Omega
equals the unforced component plus the
feedback that I get from from this
forcing tow so that's 0 1 -1 -
2 * Theta Omega okay so these are the
linear Dynamics for the system with
control and you you can check that these
igen values are actually stable they're
both minus
one so this is just a a simple
motivating example showing that it's
really nice to be able to take my System
Dynamics with external forcing and write
it like X do equal Matrix a * X Plus
Matrix B * U because then once I decide
on my control law or whatever my forcing
I want it to be I can then plug that in
and I can get a nice simp Le linear
system and I can assess the stability of
this Clos Loop controlled
system so this class is not about
controls I'm not going to ask you to
stabilize systems you know I'm not going
to ask you to cook up the tows that
would stabilize a system but you should
be able to analyze the stability of a
system that has control or forcing
applied okay so this is kind of what
we've done in the the
homework okay questions about this
before uh before moving on
yeah I'm sorry why is that not minus one
because I'm linearizing about theta
equals Pi so partial of this with
respect to Theta is minus cos Theta and
COS of Pi is minus one so I get a minus
-1
yeah okay so that was kind of the
Preamble into our disc discussion about
convolution and I'm going to try to do
this uh as kind of build up as simply as
possible how many of you have seen the
convolution integral for forcing Odes
for Odes with forcing how many of you
have never seen this okay great so we're
starting to finally get into some things
that most of you haven't seen and that
makes this a little more
interesting so let's think about this
system and what the solution X oft looks
like
so we really want to know what is the
solution to this system for various
forcing functions U and for various
System Dynamics
a and so we're going to start by looking
at case
one and case one I'm going to try to
make this as simple as possible we're
just going to assume that there is no
forcing so
um so U of T equals zero
and we have some initial
condition okay everyone with me so far
we have this system but we're going to
assume that there is no forcing ever and
we just have an initial
condition so what does the solution of
this system look like what's X of
T I mean we've solved this a lot right
so if I get rid of that term entirely
it's just the solution of x doal ax for
some initial
condition so X of T is equal to e to the
Matrix a
t * X
knot
right and we're going to call this just
like in the last uh lecture you could
call this the homogeneous solution to
this differential equation when there's
no forcing or we're going to call this
the initial condition
response this is literally just the
response of the system to a pure initial
condition with no
forcing okay
um okay so for case two this one's kind
of
interesting we're just going to build up
to more and more General systems where
eventually we're going to be dealing
with an arbitrary input U and an
arbitrary initial condition X notot
that's where we're going but we're just
going to build this up in stages so for
case two we're going to assume that
there is no initial condition x0 equals
0 so there's no kind of initial
condition and we're going to assume that
U of T equals a Delta
function and we're going to assume that
this Matrix B is just in the direction
of X
knot so essentially what this means is
that this input Matrix is just xnot
vector and I'm going to give you a Delta
function at time zero so how many of you
remember what Delta functions are and
do okay I'm going to do a little bit of
a review of Delta
functions
um
okay so let's do a little review of
Delta functions but this is the so we're
making this more and more General so
right now we've looked at the case where
there's no forcing but there's an
initial condition now we're looking at
the case where there's no initial
condition but there is forcing and soon
we're going to combine the two and we're
going to say okay there's a an impulsive
forcing and an initial condition that'll
be case
three
okay so this function delta T
is called the dra Delta
function
uh D was quite a genius uh he
essentially gave us the mathematical
notation that we use today for most of
modern
physics uh so if you've ever seen like
inner products written
as
uh like brackets that's
from dra okay this this is called the
bra and this is the Kat and that's our
bracket notation so dra was a a real
really smart guy and he invented this
function Delta because all of the
functions that had been written down and
that people used didn't have enough
generality to do the things he wanted to
do to look at Point sources and kind of
impulsive forcing of of
systems so the idea of this Delta
function is
essentially
in
time we're going to try to get unit
energy into an infinitesimal amount of
time okay it's kind of like we're going
to hit our system with a hammer so and a
very very very short amount of time
we're going to impart a finite amount of
energy or momentum into the system and
so the way we can think about this is
that in some amount of time I might
impart energy you know at some rate and
if I make that time smaller and smaller
and I double the amount of energy
imparted and I make it smaller and
smaller still the limit as I make these
rectangles infinitely thinner and
infinitely taller is a Delta
function so think of this rectangle has
height H and
width
1/h
so its area is equal to
one now if I take the limit as H goes to
Infinity every intermediate rectangle
also has area one but they're getting
thinner and thinner and they're getting
taller and
taller so the Delta function is this
kind of mathematical abstraction of the
limit as I make these rectangles thinner
and thinner and taller and
taller and it has this nice property
that if I
integrate um my Delta
function in time the area under this
curve is exactly equal to one by
construction we made this thing to be a
a rectangle with unit area and we took
the limits so this absolutely equals
one and in fact if I take the integral
from minus Epsilon to Epsilon some
really small number like minus 01 to
01 that also equals one for
any positive Epsilon any any little
number you can name if I take the
integral from negative that number to
positive that number I'll capture this
unit area increase because of this Delta
function okay so this is you know you
can think of this as an Impulse we're
impulsively adding something uh to our
integral okay questions about the Delta
function
okay it's just a special function that
we've cooked up that has this property
it always adds up to one and it's
infinitesimally thin in time it's a it's
instantaneous
okay uh you can also do something where
you um you can delay this in time so if
I
have
t0 and let's say T5
I can
have a Delta function at tal 5 it's just
delta T minus
5 okay so this is just shifting Time by
five to the right so at exactly tals 5
this thing looks like a Delta function
and it adds integrates to area one
exactly at time equals
5 so these are some of the things I can
do with a Delta function
okay now I'm going to do this example uh
that's going to illustrate case
two um maybe for case 2 I'll actually
make this an impulsive Delta function at
tals
5 this is going to make a little more
sense okay so my initial condition is
zero my input function is an Impulse at
time
five
okay and so the way I'm going to write
this is as follows I can always take
this
equation and I can multiply both sides
by DT and
integrate it's not really that useful
for computing things but mathematically
I can write that as a as the solution I
can say x of
T is equal to X
knot plus the integral from 0 to
T of
a x of to plus b
U of
to D
to this isn't really that useful for
actually Computing what x is but this is
certainly a true statement this has to
be true if this differential equation is
satisfied so any solution X of T will
definitely satisfy this integral
equation I literally just multiplied
both sides by DT and integrated and my
constant of integration is my initial
condition X
knot
okay not too bad so what we're going to
do is we're going to plot X and U in
time and we're going to see what this
impulsive input to U does to our
solution
X okay so
time
time this one is going to be
U and
X
okay
so our U function is 0 0 0 0 and then at
time five it's a Delta and then it's
zero forever
after so
U looks like a
Delta at time five so this is
zero
okay it integrates up to one
and so my X remember X not a
zero and so X of T I'm adding up a * 0 a
* 0 a * 0 a * 0 for all time less than 5
this is zero and B U is also zero for
time less than five right U and X are
both zero up to time
five so X starts at zero and stays at
zero until time five
but at exactly time five this Delta
function integrates up to
one so at exactly time five my X gains
an amount equal to b b * the integral of
Delta equals
B so we go up to
B and now this is like our initial
condition and our solution just decay
as e to
the a tus
um times the initial condition
B so I'm going to go over this one more
time because this is a little bit this
can be confusing the first time you see
it okay so what did we have here we have
a system with an initial condition equal
to
zero and our forcing is going to remain
silent until exactly T equals 5 we're
going to give it an impulsive input and
then it's going to remain zero forever
after so our solution X if it starts at
zero then x dot equal
0 plus 0 so X dots not changing until
time equals
5 at which point at time equals 5 we get
this Delta function in U which
integrates to one and since it's got
this coefficient of B it integrates to B
* 1 so our solution X at time five jumps
to an initial condition of
B and then since I turn my control off
at that
point this is just like an initial
condition response that started at time
five so I get my natural Dynamics e to
the a t times my initial condition but
now my T is shifted five units to the
right it's delayed by five units
okay questions about
this does the cartoon make
sense okay do the numbers in the cartoon
make sense does it make sense why we
have an A * T minus
5 is
itus so it's minus five because let's
say I'm at time
six so if I just imagine that my system
started at an initial condition of B
then time 6 here should really look like
e to the a * Time 1 because it's been
one unit since that initial condition so
T minus 5 is kind of my new time since
this
impulse
okay
yeah uh I made it so I gave it an
initial condition of x equals z so if I
had no forcing it all let's let's just
forget that bu ever
existed let's say I have x doal a * X
this is the solution but if my initial
condition is zero then X of T is zero
for all
time okay so X of T you can also see it
here right a * X of
to is zero until something happens in my
input and so I'm adding up zero to my
initial condition and it doesn't go
anywhere X stays Z until there's an
input
U yeah I'm a little confused because
this is the case where there the initial
condition is zero and then there's Force
right yes so what is the initial
condition that you're talking about
which is
B okay so the real initial condition of
the system is z x at time 0 is z the
system has no initial state but then
when when time five rolls around my
system gets this impulse in U and it
jumps my state X so X at Time 5 plus
some little instant after time five
equals
B and now for all time after this looks
like an initial condition of
B so it's it's it's kind of like a
pseudo initial condition the real
initial condition is zero but because of
this impulse at time five our system
looks like it has an initial condition
of B starting at time five and that
solution would be you know X of T equals
e to the A and my new time is T minus 5
times my initial condition
B and if I made b equal to some Vector X
knot then every time you see a b you
just swap out an X knot B can be
anything
sorry the graph by the second part get
exponential function uh I'm just this is
a cartoon so usually e to the a looks
like an exponential I hope it's a
decaying exponential this could be a
growing exponential or it could be an
oscillation but you know it's going to
be whatever e to the a does starting at
time five with an initial condition of
you know whatever my B
was solution we shifted the solution
yeah and that impulse gave us kind of
this pseudo initial
condition I think of these as directions
I think of X is a vector in a vector
space it has a direction and so it's the
initial condition has a Direction X knot
is a vector that points in some
direction and B could could also be a
vector that points in another Direction
and we're giving this thing an initial
condition in that b
Direction okay it's kind of the
geometric view okay so now we're ready
to do something pretty neat we're ready
to add the effects of initial conditions
and
forcing right so remember that for
linear
systems if I have two solutions that
satisfy my equation then the sum of the
solutions also satisfies my equation so
I can add Solutions and they're still
Solutions so that's going to be kind of
the whole basis of convolution
convolution is just a convoluted way of
saying a linear superposition of a lot
of
solutions okay I've seen some terrible
pictures of convolution drawn that are
super confusing and it's really really
simple okay so case three is kind of
like a baby
convolution okay so for case three we're
going to basically just add these two
we're going to say
okay U is still a Delta function at T
minus
5 and I'm just going to let my input B
be whatever it is I'm not going to
specify this Matrix
B and I have some initial
condition so now I have an initial
condition and I have some forcing some
pulsive forcing at time
five so if we have a linear system we
can just take the effect of initial
conditions and the effect of an Impulse
at five and just add the solutions
together this is kind of magical but it
totally
works it's actually not magic at all
it's just because our system is really
simple and linear it's X do equals a *
X okay so we have our initial condition
response
let's see going to try to draw this
nicely
okay okay so for the initial condition
if we acted like there was no forcing
then the initial condition would start
at X knot at time
zero and it would do whatever my natural
Dynamics a are which I'm going to draw
as an exponential decay but a could be
whatever now if I forgot that I had an
initial condition and I thought I only
had this impulsive forcing at time
five then that solution is going to look
like it's going to be zero up until time
five and then it's going to jump to B
and it's going to do whatever my
exponential decay is whatever my a
Dynamics are at time five are going to
kick in for this
impulse so this is the uh homogeneous
solution right to no forcing just the
initial condition
response and this is the uh you can
think of it as the particular
solution to the
impulse and to figure out what the true
solution is with both of these effects
it's as simple as just adding them both
together pretty
awesome so let's just add
these this one's a little harder to draw
but not
much okay so our
solution at Time Zero we have some
initial condition X knot
and until time five my initial condition
is just decaying due to the a to the e
to the at Dynamics so it's just decaying
decaying decaying decaying until at time
five I get an Impulse in U and it jumps
me up another B and then after that I
continue to Decay and Decay and Decay
and Decay and Decay
forever that's it this is the full
solution
so it's simple
addition it's not that simple it's uh
but it is just
addition okay questions about this
part
anyone
okay we're also going to start seeing
this in mat lab in a little bit we're
going to start doing some simulations
with generic forcing in mat lab but
before we do that I want to write down
the full convolution integral for the
most generic U so at this point we now
are able to combine initial conditions
with a single impul impulse in
U and the next step is actually pretty
straight
forward what we're going to do is
essentially solve this system for an
arbitrary function U you can just like
email me some Vector u in time and I can
run this through my simulation and I'm
going to assume that that
U is a train of very weak
impulses okay so the general system we
use
convolution okay this one's a little
hard to draw because it takes a lot of
vertical space but I'll do my best
um so here we're going to see the
function U of time and maybe it looks
like something like
that so now this U is not simple it's
not just an Impulse at time five or Time
Zero it's this arbitrary
function okay but if I think about
it I could say that
this is looks a lot like a bunch of very
weak
impulses being added
together and the reason I say weak is
because this U is only changing
infinitesimally in time it's only it's
smooth right so every little teeny DT it
maybe goes up or down a little teeny
du and that amount that it goes up or
down looks like
um an Impulse so this is a
train of weak
impulses and each of them has a
strength given by U at time
ttimes DT and remember DT is going to we
can take the limit as DT gets
infinitesimally small so I have this
Continuum of infinitely small weak
impulses that are contributing to this
full U function I have a train of weak
impulses each of their them has a
strength U U of T *
DT so these are like little Delta
functions
d uh Delta of t with a strength U of T
DT okay remember if these didn't have
this infinitesimal here then these would
go up to infinity and when I integrated
them I'd have a discontinuity in my
solution
which we know is not going to
happen Okay so now I'm going to draw the
solution X for the initial condition and
with the effect of all of these trains
of impulsive
forcing see
okay so first things first I'm just
going to
draw the initial condition response X
knot
so the initial condition response for
some initial condition is just you know
this Decay or growth or whatever it does
but it's just some some signal that
starts at zero and decays from X notot
forever
yeah this is just Delta of T it's a
direct Delta function with a strength
with a magnitude of U of T
DT
okay
um
good it's actually got a magnitude of
let me write this slightly better it's
really B U of T Delta of T DT it's got a
strength of B U of T times this infinite
tesol okay um I forgot this B in my
notes but shouldn't be a big deal okay
so there's this a for the this uh
initial
condition
response but then I also have the
response due to all of these little
impulses this whole continuous train of
impulses and so this is a little impulse
of size let's call this T1 T2 T3 dot dot
dot just to keep track of all these
different
impulses so I have this little impulse
of
strength B U of T1
DT and that little infinitesimal impulse
in
U gives me a tiny little transient
response starting at
T1 okay so I had my initial condition at
Time Zero it just
decays and then at T1 I get this little
infinitesimal impulse in U that gives me
a response at T2
two I get another little infinitesimal
response this one looks a little bit
bigger and at T3 and T4 and T5 and so on
for all of
time so plus plus dot dot dot
forever and so I can write this as I'm
just starting a cartoon this train of
impulses is a cartoon but what I can do
is I can can make these infinitesimally
small I can make DT go to zero and I can
write this as an
integral and so that integral is
extremely
powerful uh we have X at time
T is equal to e to the a t * X knot my
initial
condition plus this effect of impulsive
forcing plus an integral from 0 to
T of e to the
a T minus
to time
b
utau
d okay let's think about this for a
minute
so every one of these little
infinitesimal impulses in U excites a
little teeny tiny infinitesimal
exponential decay that's shifted In
Time by the amount that it took that
Delta to turn on here that's to so at
time to I have a little Delta and it
excites a response e to the A T minus
to times whatever that initial condition
was remember this is
um this is literally e to
the
A T minus
T1
B U of T1
this is what we derived from you know
case two and case three over there is
that if I had this little impulse at
time
one I would get e to the
a now my time is shifted T minus T1
right this Decay starts at T1 times
whatever the strength of that impulse
was which is b u
T1
DT and here we have e to the A T minus
T2
B U at T2 so am I forcing U at time two
times DT and so on and so forth and I'm
literally just going to add or integrate
all of those up and I get this exact
expression here this is the convolution
integral and notice
that so we can write this as we can call
this a convolution
integral this is
really e to the a t
convolved
with um B U of
T that's what this part
equals so this is the definition of a
convolution integral so this symbol star
means this type of integral where one of
the terms is shifted by
to okay so what does this mean this
means that to for any linear system at
all for any a matrix and B Matrix that
you can
name if you tell me X notot and whatever
you're forcing U is as a function of
time I can compute the solution X at any
time by adding up the initial condition
response and this kind
of time shifted integrated train of
impulse responses from my
input so every little U is kind of like
contributing to my state X but that's
dying out and so we have to add those
times shifted exponential decays for
each of those little impulses in
you okay
questions you can try this on an example
I would recommend it um because this is
a little bit abstract but you can do
something like
maybe this will be a homework I haven't
decided so maybe you have something like
x doal 5 uh minus 5x let's make it a
little simpler X do equal
minus
2x +
U and X not equal
10 and u =
s t
yeah you I'm sorry what in the in what
you've written in blue underneath yeah
yeah uh but is there supposed to be a
towel somewhere how do we understand how
much we shift
the so this integral is with respect to
D with respect to tow and so this tow
actually disappears from this integral
once you integrate once you're done
integrating this you're just left with
function of
T yeah so to is kind of this thing
that's shifting but you're going to add
all those up and you're going to get X
at T equals the sum of all of these
things X another T is the sum of all of
these things at each of those
times so this is a good example to try
this out you can really like try this
out this isn't very difficult you can
say I think we can solve it right now
this is e- 2 T * 10
plus integral 0 to T of e to-
2 T minus to S of to D to and I think
you can plug this into Mathematica and
integrate e to the something times sign
of
something and you'll get some function
out and you can plot it and see if it
really makes sense in mat lab
okay okay now I want to actually show
you some mat lab code because this is is
pretty esoteric uh it's not it's not
really esoteric but it's
only you only can see the real use of
doing this when we have computers
solving it for us okay so I probably
wouldn't ask any questions about a
generic system like this with matrixes
and something nasty on like a qualifying
exam but I do want you to know about
this idea of convolution it's like I
might ask you questions based on this
expression and this cartoon like I want
you to at least have the cartoon
understanding of
convolution um okay so I have about 10
minutes left I'll just do one last thing
and go to mat
lab so next week we're going to switch
gears entirely to numerical stuff for at
least one week we're going to talk about
numerical solutions to really nasty Odes
which will be a lot of fun because you
can solve way way harder systems than
what we're looking at
now okay so in mat lab
we typically will write down our system
like x dot equals Matrix a * X Plus
Matrix B *
U but then we'll also have an output
equation which is y = CX + du
U and the way we think about this U are
the
inputs these are the things you get to
force or change or control and y are the
outputs these are the things you get to
measure or sense or detect okay so in a
system U's are the things that you get
to force your system with and y's are
kind of the readouts of your state and X
is your internal
state so for our system we actually want
to measure everything when we do this in
mat lab we're going to want to measure
all of the X's so we're going to have um
I'm going to do this example Theta do
equal minus sin
theta plus to and we're going to do this
on the pendulum down solution so we're
going to linearize about theta equals
z and we're going to have
DDT of theta Omega
equal 0 1 - 1 0 so now we have the
negative
1 plus 01 t
and our output equation is just y = x
okay so this is
a this is
b c is going to equal the
identity and D is going to equal
zero okay and what this means is we're
going to be able to test out our
convolution integral we're going to be
able to give forcing functions to and
simulate what this system does in
response response and we're going to
measure both Theta and Omega so the
outputs are going to be Theta and Omega
cuz C is the
identity I'm going to code this up in
mat lab this should be clear once we
code it
up
[Applause]
okay okay so I'm going to clear all all
close all
CLC and I'm going to Define my a matrix
as
01 Nega 1 I'm going to add a teeny bit
of damping if that's okay with
everyone okay B is a vector a column
Vector 01 C is the identity a 2X two
identity and D is just 0
0 I'm going to call this test uh Sim
okay so in mat lab there's a super super
simple command called SS and it turns my
these four matrices into a state space
system something I can simulate so my
system equals SS of a b c and
d I save this and I run it and it takes
a little while but now I have my a
matrix B Matrix C and D matrices in
memory and I have this CIS object and if
I type CIS it tells me I have a
continuous State space
model and these are my a matrices A B C
D and so
on so now I can do something cool like I
can compute the impulse response of my
system from time Z to
100 and it looks like that so if I gave
my U an impulse at time zero this is the
impulse response of my damped pendulum
solution it oscillates and dies right
because we're at the bottom this theta
equals zero solution and this is both
the position Theta and the velocity
Omega okay so that state space
representation x doal a * X plus b * U
is really useful we can plug it into mat
lab and get impulse
responses impulse responses aren't that
great so I'm going to cook up another uh
signal which is kind of like a triangle
so it's going to my input's going to
ramp up and then ramp
down so I'm going to say tals 0 in
increments of 0.01 to 50 and U is going
to start by being
zero but then uh for a little while you
is going to ramp
up you can see what I'm doing uh
after class I'm just going to write this
out
this isn't as bad as it
looks okay so this U function I cooked
up is just a triangle wave it starts at
zero it goes up to some value then it
goes back down and then it stays
zero and I can do something called lsim
so here let's just plot T by
U that's my control
input so this to forcing function starts
at zero then it ramps up to 0.1 then it
ramps down and stays at
zero
and there's a function called lsim
linear simulation so I put in my system
my control input and the amount of time
I want to simulate and it will simulate
my system with that control Vector U
that input forcing kind of tow in
time and this is what it looks like so
if I give my system an input that looks
like this very gray triangle then these
blue curves are Theta and Theta dot for
for that in input forcing you could
literally build this system you could
build a pendulum and have something that
can apply torque at the base and you can
give it this signal and this is what the
pendulum is going to
do okay mat lab is using convolution to
compute this
solution like it's it's being clever and
it's actually Computing these integrals
in a clever way so that it gets this
blue response okay so I want you to play
around with this this is awesome stuff
you can really do powerful things with
linear systems and we're going to build
up the numerics to do nonlinear systems
uh in the next week okay happy studying
uh see you on
[Music]
Monday